I knew they'd roll follow my lead all
right I'm gonna teach you the ropes I'm
gonna teach you everything that there is
about a delay broke this is nice shady
people here man
people come in here asking for free [ __ ]
and they don't get asked for it it's a
way they ask we're like d'orsay man it's
my birthday
oh my mom no oh it's all the time in the
bay too
I got special notes were there man I got
these shape these nerves in the back
there are totally white want some
backyard buggin backyard burger bro oh
dude that's how you got to do it that's
how you got to do it people come in all
the time can I get free [ __ ] can I get
this can I get that I'll give him the
shake man I can't believe when people
look at shake they actually looking for
nubs they do is shake
there's no no they mine for gold I know
better like shaky the shake like this
like looking for gold and it's they're
gonna go and they're particular you
start pouring it no no I want that I
want that its shape its shape how are
you how are you welcome to the top how
can we help you today
strong indica we got this purple purple
here these are all the sample jars I got
some this is all you have
this is a mom-and-pop shop man this is
all we got you don't have morals good we
got a little bit of shake okay looking
for something a little cheaper man this
cake is really good this is how you
happen to get like a pound of this a
pound yeah
we don't sell pounds here man it was
uptown we're a real tough door bro or
nuts Mario fine Halloween Costco like I
get how these family like caviar gold
you guys know that what you see is what
we got man this is all we got
try this very white out man have you
singing deep is your best off yes we
good stuff that's one of my favorites I
like the strawberry banana if you want
to escape man we got there chapo to a
chocolate that one Roy is most afro you
wanna get a tunnel and ride a motorcycle
now you're in a movie Tron this is your
best weed hey Philly were the best how
much is it what do you lookin for you
want to zip you want
I don't know how much is house is 400
bucks that's our top corner bucks yeah
Wow
it's my birthday - happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you
my mom just died don't you guys do
anything for new patients yeah with a
new flat weed right here oh yeah oh
thank you man all right all right yeah
you guys are really good I'll be coming
back every day no come on
they're awesome all right thank you guys
okay good man thank you all right man
sketchy people you called it man that
dudes gonna be Trouble Man
there are questions up